brad and jennifer reunited and it feels
so good
they joined the star-studded reenactment
of fast times at ridgemont high and it
really did exceed all expectations
hi anderson hi pitt how you doing good
honey how are you doing
i'm all right the greeting moment you
just know right there you're like damn
that's that old hollywood like all the
way back to the
the 50s you know certain couples got
together and boom sparks
hi brad you know how cute i always
thought you were
i think you're so sexy jen played brad's
fast times fantasy
reenacting this famous dream sequence
will you come to me
the famous exes flirted laughed and
joked their way through the virtual live
read
wait just a minute oh god i'm so sorry i
did not know anyone who was in here cast
member julia roberts
was all of us watching along and loving
every minute
doesn't anybody knock anymore
viewers were thrilled one tweeted brad
pitt and jennifer aniston are
single-handedly saving 2020 for me
they're incredible they they came to
play there's a reason they're the
biggest
stars on the planet jen wore a red
bikini
over her tank top like phoebe cates wore
and brad who played well
brad brought a fast food pirate hat made
famous by judge reinhold
they did come to me and they asked me
who do you think should play brad and
i'm like
and they're like brad pitt and i'm like
yeah
i mean if you're casting to type i mean
it's kind of a no-brainer julia also
brought her a game
rocking a special necklace for the part
i will be playing the role of stacy
i am brad's little sister the
star-studded reading benefited sean
penn's emergency relief non-profit core
and reform alliance and in a fast times
twist
shawn played the pizza guy i guess the
early 80s equivalent of
uber eats and shia labeouf stepped into
his breakout role
the surfer bros picoli all in here some
tasty waves
we need cooler rules the cast stuck
pretty close to the script but
judge shared this set secret from the
original
i had some pretty tasty uh ad-libs there
and i know shawn did too
like in the all-american burger when
he says um no shirt no shoes no dice
and i say learn it know it
live it learn it know it
live it that was mine